julian wie hat dir gefallen war es zu
unkritisch
naja die kanzlerin hat das haben wir
eben schon gehört als begründung für
dieses gigantische debakel angegeben
hinterher ist man immer schlauer wir
investieren jedes jahr milliarden in
geheimdienste um vorher schlauer zu sein
wenn die geheimdienste nicht vorher
schlauer sind hätte man bild lesen
können da paul ronzheimer exklusiv
darüber berichtet was die taliban
geplant man hätte auch seit zehn jahren
wissen können dass die afghanische armee
niemals einem ansturm der taliban
standhalten wird das hat jeder gesehen
der in afghanistan tatsächlich vor ort
war insofern finde ich hat die
bundeskanzlerin sich hier einen sehr
schlanken fuß gemacht all das was
passiert ist hätte man vorher wissen
können wusste man vorher mann war nur
riesig und so uninteressiert an der
dramatische eskalierende lage um darauf
zu reagieren und hat die bundeswehr viel
zu spät in marsch gesetzt um unsere
eigenen staatsbürger aber auch die
menschen die uns in afghanistan
unterstützt haben dort aus dieser
dramatischen situation herauszuholen
julian wie hat dir denn die persönliche
note der kanzlerin am anfang ihrer rede
gefallen sie sprach davon dass sie auch
ein soldat kannte der dort ums leben kam
der zu ihm personenschützer team gehörte
wie kann das bei dir an
das ist natürlich bewegend aber gerade
wenn man mal in so unmittelbarer
persönlicher nähe erlebt hat was
menschen die dort ihr leben riskieren
widerfahren kann in afghanistan wäre es
doch sinnvoll diese menschen dann auch
rechtzeitig zu instruieren und nicht auf
schändliche weise dort im stich zu
lassen und dazu noch ein ganz
entscheidender punkt in den letzten
tagen haben wir immer wieder gehört von
der deutschen politik und auch von der
bundeskanzlerin wir können das ja nicht
ohne die amerikaner und da muss man
schlichtweg sagen das ist frei erfunden
angela merkel will nicht länger bleiben
als die amerikaner angela merkel hat
sich in den letzten tagen und die
letzten zwei dramatischen wochen nicht
darum gekümmert das ist eine ein bündnis
aus europäischen kräften briten
franzosen deutsche gibt die diesen
flughafen sicher natürlich kann die
bundeswehr einen flughafen sicher
natürlich können zwei drei vier große
europäische mächte einen flughafen
sichern das ist überhaupt kein problem
angela merkel will auf den letzten
metern ihrer kanzlerschaft nicht mehr
dieses risiko eingehen um den menschen
das leben zu retten die unseren soldaten
dort vor ort jahre lang das leben
gerettet haben wir lassen hier im
wahlkampf unsere engsten verbündeten die
menschen die uns vertraut haben im stich
und zurück weil wir nicht wollen nicht
weil wir nicht können und weil die
bundeskanzlerin deren aufgabe es gewesen
wäre sich nicht darum gekümmert hat dass
nach dem möglichen abzug der amerikaner
eben dann noch europäisches militär
möglicherweise sogar unter führung der
deutschen diesen flughafen sicher
militärisch kann das deutsche militär
einen flughafen von der größe in kabul
zu machen mit verbündeten absichern wer
etwas anderes behauptet er betreibt
wahlkampf und nicht eine anständige
analyse dieser dramatischen lage so wie
sich das gehören würde nun hat die
kanzlerin die argumentation auch ein
bisschen umgedreht und hat gesagt jetzt
haben wir uns mal vor wir wären im april
bereits damit begonnen die
afghanischen ortskräfte beispielsweise
herauszuholen was wäre das für ein
zeichen gewesen ein zeichen des
misstrauens nämlich in die afghanischen
strukturen die dort aufgebaut worden
sind ein argument das ja durchaus
interessante ist ja ein argument das
interessant ist aber wenn man das einmal
kurz hinterfragt oder einmal kurz
dagegen postet einfach umkippt wie ein
pappkamerad es war immer unser
versprechen an die verbündeten an die
ortskräfte aber vor allem unser
versprechen an die deutschen
staatsbürger die rechtzeitig da
rauszuholen es war immer klar es war
immer allen bewusst dass afghanistan ein
land ist dass perspektivisch wieder in
der fläche von taliban von islamisten
dominiert waren würde also jetzt im
nachhinein zu sagen wenn wir die vorher
raus geholt hätten dann wäre das
vielleicht ein schlechtes zeichen
gewesen wäre ein schlechtes zeichen ist
vor allem für die menschen die an uns
geglaubt haben dass jetzt am flughafen
von kabul stehen und uns anflehen ihr
leben zu retten und sie da raus zu holen
und wir ihn nicht das bisschen liefern
was wir ihnen immer zugesagt haben
nämlich schutz ihres lebens und das ich
kann es nur noch einmal wiederholen
nicht weil wir es nicht sondern weil der
kanzlerin der politische wille auf den
letzten so wichtigen prägenden
geschichtsbuch kriegen metern ihrer
kanzlerschaft ist und weil die cdu sich
im wahlkampf findet man will diesen
menschen nicht helfen wenn man es wollte
dann ginge das militärisch es wäre ein
risiko es könnten tatsächlich auch
deutsche truppen deutsche soldaten dabei
fallen dort vor ort aber wir haben
militär nun mal zur durchsetzung unserer
interessen und auch zur durchsetzung der
abgegebenen versprechen und dieses kann
sie versprechen hat die kanzlerin
persönlich vor wenigen wochen gegeben
und nun bricht sie es weil es ihr zu
riskant ist julian du weißt ja jahrelang
kriegsreporter und paul ronzheimer ist
ja für uns gerade verordnet ich fand es
sehr bewegend ein journalist ums zuhören
wie er gesagt hat dass jetzt die
pressefreiheit gewahrt bleiben muss dort
er hat aber auch gesagt dass jetzt schon
presse abgezogen werden soll was
empfindest du wenn du das mit bekommst
es nun die journalisten weg seien aus
afghanistan
ich bin im ständigen kontakt mit paul
ronzheimer der dort versucht unser recht
und das recht der freien welt braucht
objektive informationen durch
journalismus wahrzunehmen und man
versucht in diesen stunden ihn in ein
flugzeug zu drängen und wieder raus zu
drängen aus dem land weil natürlich
niemand zeugen haben willst du das
debakel was sich dort gerade vor ort
abspielt ich erlebe da gerade wirklich
dramatische situation wir versuchen
unser bestes auf besonders das
verteidigungsministerium das deutsche
einzuwirken dafür zu sorgen dass paul
ronzheimer dort frei berichten kann
derzeit ist der stand dass man ihn nicht
wirklich frei berichten lassen will dass
man ihn nicht mehr dort am flughafen
haben möchte wo sich diese dramatische
lage abspielt ich hoffe dass es dann
noch ein umdenken gibt denn wir erleben
gerade den zeigern moment haben wir oft
genannte dramatischen kollaps eines 20
jährigen politischen engagement aus und
dass man dabei als demokratische
regierung nach dem wir versucht haben
demokratie nach afghanistan zu bringen
presse keine nach afghanistan zu bringen
jetzt nicht mal mehr diese
pressefreiheit bereit ist aufrecht zu
erhalten in so einer mission das
empfinde ich als erschüttern und kann da
nur appellieren lassen sie brauchen
haben wir das tun was er am besten kann
ich es nämlich berichten in dieser
dramatischen lage als einziger deutscher
journalist dann auch vor ort um
informationen aus erster hand zu
bekommen und eben nicht vom hörensagen
oder von irgendwelchen zwischen
informanten in der tat wichtig ein punkt
noch ganz zum schluss vielleicht kurz
die kanzlerin hat angemerkt dass man
sich hinterfragen müssen ob man einfach
zu hohe ziele gesetzt habe was
das bringen der demokratie dorthin
angeht dass man die korruption nicht
vernünftig einbezogen hätte und das ist
kulturelle unterschiede gehen und sich
dadurch fragen für künftige missionen
erstellen ganz kurze antwort bitte
julian
alles was die kanzlerin dort
angesprochen hat haben alle ihre berater
ihr seit 16 jahren gesagt jetzt es nicht
hören wollen sie hat an einer politik
festgehalten die zum scheitern
verurteilt war juli am ende hat sie die
soldaten abgezogen die wenigstens noch
menschenleben
[Musik]